let's go next to our caller from the six
for six
area code who's calling today from six
for six is that me
yes it is oh well okay so first off love
your show I've been listening for a
while and I subscribed in everything and
I'm old enough to say this if I had a
son I'd want it to be you you're pretty
awesome there you go here's my question
here's my question for you as we move
into this election and watching what's
going on with these daily press
briefings but you're just getting
crazier and crazier by the day yep
my question for you is relating to
propaganda so do you think and I just
don't have a handle on this do you think
these like do you think the way that
Trump is approaching this this because
basically it's a propaganda salt it's
like right out of 1984 half of what he's
doing like wrong is Right leftist you
know work will make you free etc etc do
you think that this has any effect that
will help him win the election on
anything other than the base I don't
know the answer to that I really and the
reason that I don't know the answer to
that is ultimately I believe that the
election is going to depend on what is
the general perception of how he handled
the virus he clearly realizes and the
people around him realized that that is
a propaganda fight to be had so they now
are you know playing highlight videos
during press briefings they are just
telling lies they're skipping the month
of February all together in their
explanation of how well they did
so Trump knows that it's going to be a
propaganda war around the virus if the
virus is out of control
in November you would think that would
be bad for Trump except if you you have
to go out to votes that's going to be
good for Trump because it's the
trumpet's who are going to ignore
stay-at-home orders and go out to vote
whereas Democrats are more likely to
take them seriously so it's such a mess
that I have no idea how this is all
going to affect the November election I
couldn't tell you
well I just I find it
really hard to get a read on because I
mean he I'm gonna go there so I mean
I've read a lot of you know history of
Germany in the 30s and the Nazi Party
and gurbles etc etc yeah and it seems
like a lot of the techniques that he's
using are very similar to like Nazi
propaganda techniques except that it
seemed at that point the overwhelming
majority of Germans kind of went along
with that propaganda and supported it
and I'm seeing much more resistance on
in this country so it's really hard for
me to get a read on whether it's working
or not because I'm trying to figure out
is the base enough and I've got in my
bones I feel like if the base just votes
for him that's not enough for him to win
right so here's the the answer we don't
have mandatory voting in the country
roughly half the country doesn't vote so
the base is enough right if a bunch of
people stay home and don't vote that's
that that's the unfortunate reality what
your so the techniques being used by
Trump knowingly or unknowingly are
reminiscent of some of what we saw in in
the pre World War two Germany phase that
doesn't mean Trump is Hitler right to be
clear that's not what we're saying
no of course not because because we have
independent media alternatives to Trump
Trump's propaganda his base is highly
propagandized right 99 they'd never
abandon him that that contingent but
then you've got a whole bunch of other
no and they never will you've got a
whole bunch of other people who don't
fall for it the question is are they
going to go out and vote in November and
I just don't have the answer I don't
know okay I mean and I mean that's
basically it I mean the only other thing
that I would say is I feel like nothing
that he's doing is moving the needle on
independence or getting people to vote
in other words right think that he's
doing indicates to me that he is getting
new votes or getting people to change
their mind so that leaves it to the base
so I guess you're right and but part of
me also is like because I've had these
conversations with about five or six
different people we're talking about
people that voted for Jill Stein people
that voted third party in the last
election and they said to me guess what
not making that mistake again so I'm
wondering if there are a number of
people that quote took a chance on him
and then
decided are now like oh my god this is a
nightmare like that's not gonna happen
we'll know when we get the 2020 exit
polls but in the meantime the the sort
of turnout idea that you're talking
about the political scientist rachel
bike coffer has written about this quite
a bit and and we're gonna interview her
on the show very soon and and it's a
it's it's it's about turnout ultimately
is what you're saying and i tend to
agree with you
excellent well i look forward to that
interview and love the show and i'm
happy to be a supporter thank you so
much i so appreciate it great to hear
from you and hope to hear from you again